decker agent jackson we'll be working
with him on this mission
agent jackson let's get one thing
straight i don't like orders
and i don't play by the rules i trust
you heard of me
actually no i haven't oh wow
[Music]
that's my sergeant crandall united
stands i'm a recruiter how y'all doing
this is my associate sergeant graham
nice feet gentlemen we want to talk to
you about your future and where you fit
in the united states army y'all yeah in
case you haven't heard
we're asking and you're telling that's
right no restrictions man you're gonna
be surrounded by dudes all day
y'all get exercise together you can
shower together talk about soap
water the worst now i know what you're
thinking the arm is dangerous but the
fact of the matter is
everything's dangerous all depends on
what's your definition of the word
danger is oh yeah what all right
oh here we go we got my friend all right
hey maybe i already got him but you're
better off in the army cause we're gonna
get you in the best set
in your whole life talking about a
six-pack gonna give you an eight-pack
slip hey we'll even give you a jet pack
that's a joke man here you'll get a
funny guy we got your bags
[Music]
man combat is just a bunch of men in a
tight space with flashing lights and
loud noises
just like this yeah you're right at home
it's gonna be great man y'all gonna love
it oh here it is
can't stop it okay stop it what no what
start
no prandtl crandall and hold it what the
[ __ ] you gotta do
is hold it right there
excuse me there young man have you ever
thought about joining the united states
army
just oh oh excuse me i will uh talk to
you too late to follow me
[Music]
[Applause]
decker agent jackson you'll be working
with him on this mission
agent jackson let's get one thing
straight i don't like
orders and i don't play by the rules
i trust you heard of me actually no i
[Music]
haven't
we don't have much time the arachnid
agents have taken over the consult we
need to get you
in and resolve this from the inside
we've taken the latest sit rep of the
hostiles position and we've
reconstructed
a holographic blueprint of the consulate
save the mouth squirt for the newer
occurs
general i'm not gonna be impressed by
any facial technology
it's just a 3d representation
i'm pretty standard these days all right
i know what it is agent jackson you will
enter through this ac duct on the south
side of the building
yes sir decker you will be dropped on
top
and then you will gain access through
this elevator shaft we want you to go
down to the fourth floor
mate decker
you okay heard everything you said
elevator shaft oh
it's bright yeah it's bright the
terrorists are located on the third and
fifth
floor of the building each floor has six
groups of six men what we're gonna want
you to do is stop in the middle at the
fourth
and pry open the elevator door and go
i just want you to move through that
elevator door and then go down
[Music]
pry open
elevator door go down to the third floor
[Music]
okay maybe this isn't gonna work out why
what's the matter general
everybody's putting their hand in the
laser
it's not a laser it's a hologram
tomato tomato look what's with all the
babysitting and hand-holding papa's a
big boy
let's zoom into the interior yeah let's
do it
let's cut to the chase why am i here
your primary target is your old rival
from the cold war
nikolai androkovich
good job decker jackson was an
undercover agent for arachnid
how in the world did you know
ain't my first rodeo
[Applause]
in my day we made coffee hot
he's here he's here come on baby come on
get your sign brandon bring the camera
come on let's go
hold it out hold on right for daddy so
daddy can see
there you go
oh my boy there's more
my god i love you so much rock oh hey
let's go come on boys good dog good dog
there we go
oh i missed you so much
gentlemen it has been a pleasure and an
honor
to meet you and uh your your people the
us government
supports you in every possible way
ideologically of course however we
cannot offer any military aid at this
time
with all due respect ambassador we need
more than that
we are dealing with terrorism on a daily
basis oh that's unfortunate
warlords overrun villages yes that's
regrettable rapes
tortures all manner of uh human
atrocities that's really sad
but the u.s military has simply spread
too thin we can't afford another
intervention at this time
but what we could use your help with
really is protecting our vulnerable
plentiful and newly discovered oil
reserves oil
excuse me one second operation golden
eagle is a go
welcome to democracy
uh we also have natural gases oh yes a
lot lots of it
our forces have been devastated the
enemy
is at the edge of the village there are
not many others left
should we surrender
you may surrender django
but i'm afraid that is a luxury i cannot
afford
you have no idea what they do to
warlords if they capture me
they will torture me for weeks and that
is nowhere to go
i want you my most trusted soldier over
the age of eight
to take my life that is
my final water
he's trying to kill you sir not with
this there's a gun in the drawer
oh so sorry okay amazing
you missed every vital organ django
found it all right now kill me jingle
hurry please
i thought you might want an open casket
you are an idiot
ah don't say that i did try my best
shoot me
in the end you imbecile oh
god oh goodbye commander
you saw the ass piece of sh
did you just insult me as you were about
to fire
oh well you had insulted me earlier
i i thought you would be dead huh
ooh so sorry ow
ow ow now stop stopping what the hell
are you doing gun is empty
would you like i stab you again no no no
please
django there are bullets they are over
there okay
tango please happy i am
i thought i could kill you very quick by
hitting you with that big cooking pot oh
my god would you breeze i mean please
get it over with
attack i did not find the bullets but
better
boiling hot water what are you going to
do with it
i surrender i am the general german egg
boujou
i am commander don't go they torture you
[Music]
so
[Music]
i was wondering when i would come in
here to find you sitting in that chair
wasn't easy tracking you down decker
i wasn't supposed to be
i know you're retired but that's all
behind me now
general i'm not the man
you knew during the cold war i
understand
we're now facing a threat unlike any
we've ever faced before
a man with your expertise i made a vow
never to kill another human being
sorry general gonna have to find someone
else
oh no we uh
we weren't thinking you'd do it we were
just hoping you could recommend someone
for the job
i guess i could come out of retirement
no
no need just a recommendation we'll do
all right
i'll do it you know you're just not what
we're looking for you
sly son of a [ __ ] you always knew how
to push my buttons
i'm in not you decker
sharp as i ever was even faster too
grab my hand nope
wait till i count to three first one
two three okay
i want you to try and slap me in the
face oh i wasn't ready for that
try again oh okay you know what
yeah what didn't have my adrenaline up
cause this is not an actual high-stakes
situation
all right draw your weapon
and disarmed
you're getting pretty quick and disarmed
okay i don't need to take your weapon
[Music]
you know what shoot me i am not going to
shoot you
wing me in the shoulder this is
ridiculous try
general see what happens
deflected
okay i made a mistake coming here wing
me in the other shoulder
i'd rather not i insist
that was because my other arm was
already injured okay i'm leaving
all right all or nothing gut shot
no gut shot come on if you can shoot me
in the gut i'll concede
decker you have two wounded arms gotcha
go
guard it
[Music]
you you caught the bullet
so you're telling me that the bullet is
in between your hands
right now
is that all you got come on
headshot
headshot let's go i'm ready
i was wait one second though